a lab just discovered a cell that might
be quite literally the cure for cancer
yeah and get this it was found
completely by accident it was an
accident
they phone up I asked can you believe
that any it's crazy by accident they
found it yeah yeah completely by
accident yeah yeah and this is such an
important story that I had to invite the
people responsible to come on the show
and talk about it please welcome via
satellite dr. Murphy and the intern who
accidentally found the cell
Jakub welcome welcome to our show this
is very exciting yeah thank you for
having us Conan I dedicated 15 years of
my life to intensive gene therapy in the
fight against cancer it's just an honor
to present my research it's just
incredible but let me get this straight
Jacob you were the one who actually
discovered the cure yeah dude it was me
total accident first day on the job how
funny
an intern just shows up and whoops he's
the one who finds it yeah okay well
Jacob walk us through how it happened
okay yeah well I was actually in the lab
that day because I failed microbiology
last semester so I I just like I chose
an internship at random and then I was
looking through the what's the thing a
microscope microphone yeah and and then
one of the things looked like weird
what's it called a cell yeah so so what
tipped you off that this cell was
different
oh well the other cell thing he's
renormalize all this other one and
called dr. Murphy over to make a look at
it yeah regular cells have an asymmetric
membrane and then there was one so they
look like a boob okay yeah and now I'm
the guy who found the cure for cancer
okay I mean Jacob this is crazy your
name is gonna be in history books and
you're definitely getting a Nobel Prize
so after that crazy discovery Jacob what
did you do for the rest of the day uh I
think I probably like jerked off and
went to bed
[Applause]
you know what's great Jacob because
you've found the potential cure you get
to name it all right oh man I never
thought of that I I'm gonna name it Jeff
Jack I have a buddy named Jeff and he
loves boobs graduations Jacob and I'm
sorry what was your name again
dr. Enid Murphy PhD okay we should
definitely hang sometime hey that'd be
great I'd love to hang out with you
anytime
you